well it's a staggering increase that
affects thousands unemployment claims
continue to climb across our state with
initial claims of 36 percent compared to
last week
the second biggest jump in claim
activity since mid-october
now the number of initial claims filed
for pandemic unemployment assistance
pua was up more than 600 percent
no surprised eater says this is raising
some red flags the i-team's david charns
is live
in the newsroom with what we know and
what people are saying about
it david hey kirsten this spike sticking
out for sure
more than 61 thousand initial pua claims
filed last week that's
a 635 yes 635 percent
jump from the week before today we
talked to three people in our area
looking for help having trouble getting
it
and they're just now furious
not only infuriated but i'm not often
then you just call
and call and call it's mostly just like
worrisome just not
having any stability nine months into
this pandemic and out of work
we've heard it over and over the idea is
that you don't go broke
and you help you out until you get back
on your feet problems getting in touch
with dieter and getting help paying the
bills
robert phillips is one of those people
he's been waiting
months just to hear if he's eligible all
i expect is an answer to
routine correspondence i have filed for
unemployment
july the 19th a reasonable an average
person on the street would expect within
a month
maybe six weeks using post office rules
you know
things take time but not going on five
months without a dime on something
that's really critical
then news friday that first time
claimants for pua benefits
those for contract and gig workers
jumped more than
600 percent from the week before this
graph showing that huge spike
in its raising red flags it is
frustrating because
you are left with that with all of these
questions that
you need answered jamie reiser is a
substitute teacher and says dieter
asked her to send money back but she
says she can't get in touch with them
and she's frustrated
there are going to be people that scam
the system and hopefully they're the
ones that get caught and have to pay the
money back not the people that
need it caitlyn ducette lost her job in
april
she too has yet to hear anything but
it's just
very frustrating especially to see like
so many people getting
their benefits and they're getting you
know the pandemic assistance and they're
getting the extra weeks
and it's like i haven't even you know
got a phone call
back in a statement a deter spokeswoman
says this marked increase
is questionable given the underlying
economic conditions
now we did talk to several other people
today who said it's not
fair that those cheating the system are
getting money while they're still
waiting to even hear if
they can get benefits the itim did reach
out to dieter to get more information on
all this today
and we did not hear back live in the
newsroom i'm david charns 8 news now